you'd love to make a statement don't you
I never said I was subtle
hey okay I mean you make everything your
fashion run away
with all of your looks and tonight is no
exception is this denim yes ma'am it's
denim appropriate for a romantic comedy
that told me to dress casual oh you know
I thought it was weird this whole thing
Nick you don't look too bad either Mr
Jonas just happy to be here just happy
to be here and can I say I was so happy
to see y'all at the Met Gala carpet
because y'all made quite the splash but
how is it getting back to that carpet
that's kind of weird all first video
it did I mean the whole time because you
know you stand for a long time in that
line yeah um we just kept talking about
the moments where we had met what had
happened and it was really fun to
reminisce oh and then you had both of
your girls getting ready at the same
time little multi and free she was doing
last looks final touches of my time and
the little one approved it looks of
course right very much does she likes
everything shiny she loves diamonds I
mean
this girl that was a shiny diamond right
there she kept going for that diamond
I'm sure she did there's nothing wrong
with putting herself back out there
again did you go in there get the D you
make it sound like I have a vitamin
deficiency yeah you kind of do you have
a vitamin D deficiency now this
character here you are going for because
I feel like we haven't really seen this
vulnerable side of you and I had a
character like this so what did you
enjoy about taking on this character I
love that love again it's an Ode to the
romantic movies from the 90s you know
like Sleepless in Seattle
thank you um Jerry Maguire that make you
want to cry and laugh and like feel warm
and I haven't been able to do that in
America as much as I have done in India
before so I was very excited to do
Citadel and love again at the same time
I mean you just need one more project
for me I know just you know casually
busy yeah no just casually but he didn't
actually worked this man here and is
this your first role together on the big
screen together yeah
well I mean I'm hardly in it just well
you were kind enough to do a really
really sweet Cameo and save me actually
this is my knight in shining armor I was
supposed to do this scene would actor
like licks my face in slow motion oh God
exactly
so how many takes did that scene today
it's a lot of practice before I was
there okay okay this is not easy after
dark Jonas okay but no you guys have a
disastrous first date with this one
you're obviously
but in real life it was the first date
was it a golden one was it a good one it
was beautiful I mean I was 45 minutes
late but besides that it was because she
had to be looking fashionably some
points of course so who's like the most
romantic one of the two of you
I I think we we outdo each other yeah we
one-up each other at every turn yeah I
don't know how long that's gonna last
though we have to like get realistic
about yeah we do no that's getting crazy
you gonna be hitting the road with this
one whenever he's out with the Jonas
Brothers for their what 35 City Tour
yeah or something like that yeah we just
announced the whole thing yesterday I'm
very excited congratulations she's gonna
be busy shooting doing her thing but I'm
hopeful she can come out for some of it
I'm really excited to come to Dodger
Stadium that was where
um Nick took me to one of our early
dates to be able to see them sell out
not just doing really cool oh my God I
love how y'all are always figure each
other's biggest fans so always great to
see all together have fun
[Music]
thank you